hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to the Callisto protocol
this is made by some of the same
developers who made dead space and I
think you're going to see a lot of The
Inspirations and similarities between
them because I think it takes place in
space and I think there's a lot of dead
things which usually means that things
are going to go poorly for me
well there's your dead
uh there's more dead I haven't seen
space yet
well hey that's Korean
oh interesting
some kind of restaurant
where are we
a little bizarre
oh no
oh he doesn't look good
okay so we're dealing with some kind of
infection
oh
interesting
led by the notorious Danny Nakamura
that guy's sweaty Roger hanger control
laying in course for Europa station
space space there it is even this is
similar to dead space like just the way
the interfaces are the brown of it you
got something to say You're Gonna Keep
flicking that thing all day
I was watching that
it's our last run Max
I'm done talking about it
and what do you want me to say well
thank you
because after this job we're never gonna
have to work another day in our lives
well I guess you got it all figured out
I guess so
and what is this huh
back and forth Callisto to Europa all
this additional security it's a prison
Moon Max
they take the security pretty serious
and what about the attacks oh how do you
explain that by the outer way
they've been hitting targets all over
the sector for the past six months
we got a yellow light in the cargo holds
and it's probably nothing well it's
still worth checking out
shouldn't worry so much you know
live longer huh
okay they said that there were some
sensors are both showing errors go check
them out yeah that doesn't seem oh
this doesn't seem like it's going to be
as bad as some people have claimed but
some people did say that the performance
does stutter a bit let me
holy crap my mouse was way too high
there we go
you going or what yeah I'm going shut up
it's okay
man you know it's so weird because it's
been a long time since I played a triple
A game on uh my channel here and the
fact that it kind of stutters I gotta
tell you I've got the best computer
money can buy right now well pretty
close anyway outside of a supercomputer
but I've got two 40 90s I got two of
them they don't exactly work in
conjunction for games like this but it's
still a 40 90 and you think that it
would work properly I've got like the
fastest hard drives and everything like
that so I imagine that this is going to
get patched but for now with this
computer it's not too bad
it is cool though God look at the detail
oh man Indie developers wish they could
God look at all the detail you don't
even look at the ceiling you don't even
notice any of it you don't notice none
of it
yeah
why do I walk like I gotta [__] in my
pants I really do look like I gotta go
to the bathroom real bad
all right come on Max you gotta stack
these right
ah good tutorial and take off your
jacket if it's so damn sweaty you don't
need to wear that
oh radioactive that's probably fine
yes
yeah I should I should definitely check
out the rest of the ship now how am I
gonna do that with all these obstacles
in the way
I could never I'd never be able to
it's impossible
God damn it looks good though man it's
just it's just like I'm sorry I'm
basking the glow I've been playing so
many like like and not that there's
anything wrong with it Indie developers
they need all the love that they thing
what did I just see
I just see what the hell did I just say
can I not go down there really is this
chest eye wall really stopping me am I
not supposed to go in the darkness it
really seems like I'm supposed to go
down there but uh
impassable impossible even
God I can't even imagine the Polish that
goes into every single step like every
single step every look every slight
animation like oh what was that behind
me oh God and that's why I don't like uh
something getting a bad rap just because
like it has some launch Day Jitters too
many games gets shot down too early just
because they're like on launch day they
had some issues
oh
God I'm dumb okay I hope lexian you
saved me from that hope you made me look
real smart and I didn't look to my right
I guess when I turned around left
oh Steam
oh God
I guess I'll check the
I have nothing to say about that
I have nothing to say about that at all
what's to be worried about me worry
never not on your life not on anyone's
life mantle
mantle you're gonna could climb clamber
climb mantle really mantle all right
whatever
maybe that's the technical term for it I
don't even know
could be
beautiful hello
I'm detecting something sinister
occurred here ah
we've been boarded
the other way
when you get your ass back up here
you know it could be anywhere
yeah well they could be anywhere but
they're not here clearly
also you'd think that there would have
been more sensors about being boarded
that seems like a more obvious problem
oh wow cool though I'm really into that
I love that a lot
also I didn't actually expect to go
through the fire to get back
seemed like that would have been a
roundabout way I thought I was going to
explore some more oh yes the secrets of
the Crouch
no no not our nukes not the nukes
all right yep not my problem anymore
good thing I'm gonna get he's shimmy
shimmy squeeze squeeze squaws I'm okay
with shimmy shammy
Field's still in effect
for long
am I still dreaming I'm still shimmying
apparently
what should I know
anything nothing yet
almost out of time out of time for what
I don't even know what you're in time
for hey it's the way that I was trying
to go before but I couldn't before yeah
there he is there I am Max ready for the
bridge yeah definitely
I'm climbing It's so dead space this is
exactly a dead space thing more
specifically a dead space
two three three thing I think I remember
something from this Jacob
get up hey shut up I'm trying look at
what I'm trying to do and look what you
do
can I jump across this or something
there we go
I'm I'm hurrying
do you see what I'm working with man's
gravity
oh God did you notice the fire
oh I'm flying why do I gotta fly I don't
think I'm qualified
[Music]
I got no choice
coming in high who's the anagram
already at maximum We're not gonna make
it am I flying we are watch out hold on
I raced
I feel like everything
that I could have done crouching
mantling shimmying
I did everything I could and if I
crashed the ship it wasn't my fault
I shimmied with the best of them
I made it
good
I told you not I told you not to hurry
yeah buddy who's definitely alive God I
hope your head is intact told you to
keep your uh
Max
oh no I called it God I called it God I
called it
what
hey hey come on come on
I've listened I I shimmied bro dude
friend working partner
a shimmy
I mantled what is happening
of all the things I expected to walk
through that door you weren't expected
continuing search uh-huh
black iron security you the pilot
yep again
we'll just need the one
okay uh
let's get you out of here
all right thanks dude manifest says you
were running cargo out of the hangar
don't give many of you Freelancers out
here
I was just doing my job do it I know it
is
sir
yes sir
whatever you say grab him too
hey what are you doing this is
unexpected hey
do anything
hey I know I shimmied a man told and I
crouched I definitely did those things
those are things that I did
well that's one way to start a game I
suppose I just caught the graphics it's
a little stuttery here and there but
God I'm being treated I'm being treated
no that says
it doesn't say outbreak
Glenn
way too late [__]
okay uh inmates do not speak unless they
are spoken to it there's been a mistake
my name is Jacob Lee I'm not an enemy
you were inmate
three two dish five two one you you
address me is Captain Ferris what no no
I'm just a cargo pilot I was attacked by
the outer weight by her she crashed my
ship and she killed my first officer I
don't care Warden sword oh speak of the
devil oh hi Warden
's choice in your life
the only place where you truly belong
to find the one thing that has always
been missing
a purpose for your
life
and together we will find that purpose
for welcome to Black Iron prison
love that last part
give me some chills every time end of
the line get up
well good thing what Warden says is law
inmates
I gave you a direct voice this is not
right I don't belong here
listen
you know they call Callisto the dead
Moon
dead
just like you would have been if I
hadn't fished you out of that wreck
I mean [__] as far as anyone else is
concerned you are dead
time you moved on
because you're crossing over to a New
Kingdom now
my kingdom
so whatever it is you're holding on to
right there that's your old life you
gotta let that go because your new life
is entirely
in my hands
nice hands
strong grip you
but you shimmy with the best of them
okay
forever let's go you mantle with those
hands
I mental with these
hi you're handsome oh
is it like United Jupiter or something I
hope not United Jupiter corporation that
would spell a dismal future
oh yeah
wait no maybe
oh
hey what's up
4-1-2 of the ujc penal code you will now
be fitted
core device a doctor he's not in the
system we don't know just prep the
device
that device no no you're a goddamn
doctor yes my intent to Faithfully
execute my responsibilities try not to
move and let me make things worse
ah
all right
doctor he's flatlining
that's nice
and sleepy time
I'm guessing that's supposed to be my
health bar
s
foreign
or reality on Jupiter it could be you
never know hi whoa whoa hey handsome how
you doing
hello God it's cool
oh it's a little stuttery but it's cool
high what is this supposed to be
yeah I remember that from the news
it's not a drill
please
remain calm
I'm dip something's all right no
I don't know why that was funny to me
God
no something Evil's in the air something
definitely is off
very strange usually the fires aren't
this hot out here
the debris is only slightly less
ramshackled than it's been oh my God
yeah who's got what hello
is it that's happening oh that was that
what I was oh godding okay that's
probably what I was oh Gotti
okay
um
hello oh you're broken
oh I don't know what that is what in the
hell am I looking at
oh it's a dead body
I thought those were heads I thought it
was a two-headed creature just it's just
a desiccated corpse
hi how you doing pal good to see you
anyway you guys still running around and
waving your arms
good job guys keep it up keep up the
good work
[Music]
look just freaking God
your tail
through I walked through it and
do it in seconds well it took me like a
minute but I walked through it so quick
and I'm barely looking at it look at all
this detail that I'm I'm barely even
looking at
God hi who are you I'm bip
well I'll leave you to it
okay anyone seen a marker around here
Mayan
anomaly I remember there being an
anomaly in my ship you guys got borders
whoa
hey man what's up how you doing
hey good to see you
what the [__] is going on I don't know
what the hell's going on
crash I got thrown in here and then
look I've been in here half my life I
know this place I've got a plan to get
out if you help me I already sell I'll
help you yeah
to get us out of control across that
bridge you can open myself from there
all right
Jacob don't use it Jacob save your life
all right you got it Elias I'm
definitely gonna get you out of this
alive don't worry about a thing don't
worry Elias I'm completely reliable and
you can trust me and you're definitely
gonna make it oops that's not
vault
that's vault can I stomp oh
oh
yes yes yes yes yes
God I can't wait for the Dead Space
remake yeah not that it necessarily
needed to be remade but
I still got some good vibe from this
ah
ah shimmy
I remember this from my training
I'm a little rusty on my shimmy
yeah that was oh that was a close one
man I was worried
here or not there here hey you guys
still running around in a panic hey good
good wouldn't expect anything else
keep it up the wardens watching
are you still murdering people over
there you guys just run in laps what are
you doing
all right
good thing everyone is every every
single door is fixed by a slice of the
cables ah
hey you oh ow
hey oh
ah
is that always gonna be a move that I
need
wait
wait should I
you didn't need to pierce both your
hands on that
with me
well good thing I just learned how to
deal oh okay all right hold on a second
I'll Dodge I'll Dodge oh okay that
didn't work I'll Dodge this time yeah
that's how I do yeah yep I just learned
so that actually is how combat Works
interesting hey I thought I dodged that
there we go so I can get two hats in hey
oh I died whoa I dodged that I thought
anyway
oh
man like I don't want to give a game of
[__] so it's okay it's okay we're gonna
get through this together together we
advance
oh I see
interesting maybe I thought that was
like there's no way that it'll die
whoa whoa okay the stuttering doesn't
help
okay interesting I did Dodge
ow
oh oh I'm oh I see
um
hold on everybody
[Applause]
okay there we have it we did it
everybody thank you so much for having
the patience to be there with me yo what
the [__] was that I don't even know hey
Elias buddy bro don't worry I'm touching
nothing
what's she doing
okay all right hi oh he did you did get
out I thought he would have been dead
for sure okay is there anything else in
here that I need and am I probably
infected with whatever the thing was
that infected whoa
there isn't a timing window just be
holding down a or D before
see that that is essential information
I don't need to time it ah
oh and then alternator else it'll okay I
understand I feel like that whole
sequence was meant to teach me that
and yet it didn't
but well all right carrying on
hey Elise oh hey yeah
I just saw something
what do you want about I know what I saw
look this place can mess with your head
this is our chance whatever it was you
saw it's all the more reason to get out
of it see that Watchtower
yeah that's our first stop meet me there
how Elevate us that way take it up to
the next level I'll be in touch got it
okay thanks buddy thanks best friend
can't wait for us to get out of here
alive thank you so much for being you
and allowing me to be myself
that's what two friends are all about
hey you want to let me uh hold the block
attacks oh
well I don't want to do that hey I'm
holding oh you better watch out and I'm
alternating
oh
okay all right interesting
try me
oh God
kind of tough ain't it
oh it still takes some getting
[Music]
yeast yes
it's not as visceral though
I think it's got to be more visceral
gotta get more screamy can I stomp on
anyone's corpse
take this and that yeah without without
Isaac Clarke's
just not the same
no
elixion can you add in Isaac Clark's
scream whenever I stomp I know that
sounds like a lot of work that's because
it is so thank you
you don't have to do that
yeah how
much
fine I see you made it
to them
down I thought this is in the elevator
it's just a lift
I thought it was an elevator
I thought all right I
I guess that's the difference between
mantle and Vault and shimmy and clamber
and climb
I don't know anything about this place
anything at all
what message
we are going to die we are all going to
die oh okay well that's
good sentiment oh sorry Lexi and I was
taking your job from you I apologize
why did that need such a fancy animation
to crawl through a hole I can create
with their anyway hey what's up bro hey
we're talking about Miss Me Oh kiss this
hey watch this
oh god oh
all right that felt good are you guys uh
okay you guys dream about some kind of a
marker
unitologist ideals flowing through your
mind okay whatever
should I inject myself
[Music]
three okay here I go let's see what
happens
that felt good
that felt bad that felt ow
uh why why why
right
again I don't think I actually touched
anything there
I'm not sure every single interface can
be controlled with something's wrong
with the elevator I'm heading down not
up
I don't
I don't know if I want to go to solitary
solitary sounds spooky and lonely but
hey there's a friend
I thought I saw a chat over person
all right anybody here
anybody at all
anybody
thank you Isaac
cages seem a little uh
all right what's up
I'll call my name
you
I guess not
what energy converter for what do I have
energy
valuable Contraband items can be sold
for credit to who whom
I just gotta say in the grand scheme of
things I know it's a common thing in a
lot of games that when you open a door
there's like some extra element to it
are there people out there that are
thrilled by that moment that when you
get to a door and it's like spam e on
this to put effort in I'm like I'm
connected to the game oh gosh look I'm
there does anyone actually do that I
don't mean to [__] on this particular
but it's it's just like a common thing
it's like I'm so used to you go up to
the door you press to eat open is it
better maybe it fell it felt better I
think it felt a lot better am I cynical
am I an [__]
yes but I can't even well there's I
don't think this toil flushes anyway
maybe I should back away from that God
the detail who is responsible to make
the toilet poop really just nah really
in there oh
man whoever admit oh shimmy
ah good
credits
I don't know if the deodorant's gonna do
you any good on the toilet room there
wow I don't know if that helps
I don't know if it helps
anyway
oh this looks ominous
there's something
clunking
not the Deep clunk the small clunks
I know it's I I know what that is though
it's a loading screen right that's what
it's supposed to be it's I know they use
doors as convenient ways to hide loading
but they all sit it in Dead Space and
they just made it go
and then it would open when it was done
I do feel more engaged though
anyone here to like up
some kind of bird squawking in the
distance anyone hear that is that just
me
okay The Vibes
the immaculate vibes
did everyone just [__] themselves to
death is that is that a common alley in
here
you'd think that it wouldn't be every
cell but it's every cell
it's it's every cell
okay
[Music]
what if I don't
oh it doesn't do if I didn't press
oh I can fail it
well I'm so sorry I didn't know that I
could feel the door puzzle
[Music]
and God damn I'm sorry I'm just not good
enough to get through this
oh I don't know how
there we go
I'm sorry I don't mean to I'm
beginning to laugh
okay
you hurt
my baby baby
didn't catch that last part Elias
something uh crazy happened there I was
just minding my own business definitely
not stomping on corpses and this
freaking baby jumped at me had to put it
down
he's getting a little out of control
ah
nice what oh that all right that is nice
that was incredibly nice I like the
Ambiance here I just gotta say this area
here
I mean all these areas so far just ah
the detail
The Vibes here are very good
um definitely not what in the hell
thank you
uh-huh uh-huh
okay
Elias found the elevator heading up now
now we're talking
it's a good place to gear up you need to
watch out now
there were big Robos okay that was cool
this is cool all right now I'm getting
into this
I may have been a little you know well
deserved or not
but I'm I'm here for the Vibes
no no we're not infected lethal Force
has been authorized
area secured moving to Medical Center
I love the designs of those robots uh
sorry guys God damn uh sorry about that
man I could have not done anything about
that I love those Robos
they are super cool they're a little bit
of the uh
like Star Wars droid like the bigger
ones not the skinny little guys is there
a place I can shimmy or is this vaulting
this mounting vaulting what am I doing
here
oh mantle
oh
I'm an old pro at this sneaking's like
my middle name
I don't even remember my first name stay
out of sight
all right you got it 100
easy peasy not a problem movement
detected yeah and you're not gonna
detect any movement idiot
um
that's gonna save me no
no no don't do it don't do it
don't do it
that's what I thought you oh though I
had cover here I didn't even uh I see
I hope you don't hear this
good thing I did that quietly
there's something on the other side that
I need looks like there might be but I
don't have the nearly the just stay low
no activity detected yeah no brain
activity dumbass
all right
easy peasy
uh where am I
okay good implant
I don't know if I want to be here
is this where I got my core
uh
brain activity moderate well there's
your problem it's not a brain you're
looking at right there [__] dummy
like no one knew what they were doing
here
looks like I'm in the clear I'm in the
clear
brain activity
you know I
actor I
what does this do
I like shiny
never mind I took it
it's dark now why is it dark now
hello
go with another baby
I hate surprise box baby
anyway
good thing I have one of these
uh good for me
okay I don't think I have any kind of a
map or anything so I think I'm kind of
on my own as far as
figuring out my way just gotta go with
the natural layout of this place and
I've
whoa
I have inventory I didn't even know that
oh I wow I do energy converter I don't
even know uh Alt yeah
oh
wait
I have to keep this up while I'm looking
at it
no there we go for the first time
the promise here
the opportunity that lies ahead I
thought you were going to continue away
oh God weirdo
right
see I don't know what I'm supposed to do
about that move there
were you tired
there we go or not
okay
good enough thank you for the money
apparently because uh I guess that has
use here
don't know why unless there's some kind
of a store like there was in Dead Space
Mayhem
hello
I got a bad feeling about this
oh I got a bad feeling about this
lockdown huh
launch your eyes everybody
I can't even look at that myself
indeed yes wise words Wise Wise words
one might say we must unite to become
one under a marker of some kind yes let
us be United once more also was Health
really just on like a holographic card
there
very impressive
[Music]
I made it through the Infirmary
still looking for that weapons lock up
all right stay alive
well
oh I have a friend here
you'll ah you see me do you
huh am I supposed to be able to take two
of you guys
oh
how am I supposed to know if it's a
series of attacks and not
oh interesting
ah you both can gang up on me at the
same time that seems hardly fair
come on
there we go whoa whoa
we got an acrobat on our ends
uh you have guts to give me something
you still gonna pop out somewhere
oh it is very dead space then
you gonna pop out
those look mean
I wonder if I'd have killed them near
them if I would have like done a sweet
animation to kick it into the the vents
would have been pretty cool
but I don't know
might be you never know though
[Music]
the lockup had already been raided all
that's left is this baton
okay
oh that could have been incredibly
useful as a tool of Leverage but
whatever
yeah see you there hello whatever you
say about it whatever you say whatever
you say whatever you say all right
so God it sounds cool though I do like
it it's like a workbench or something
nah
couldn't have been
that's locked you're blocked
oh of course
oh
no
environmental kills
I do like that that is okay with me I am
down with that
I'm very okay with that so that's what I
suspected why else would you have big
swinging fans who's there
who's there
in the walls
where are the walls I saw those some
other people screaming
oh
see now I'm getting into it now I'm
liking it
now I'm really feeling it
look at that
details in here
God damn it's cool
yeah the combat's different because it's
just like not something I've ever done
before
in a game like this
but it is interesting it's kind of
intuitive you do have to look at your
enemies and you do have to kind of read
their moves and you kind of got to be
aware
that's not bad
I don't like it all right so I'm back
here which is great progress that I've
made
great yeah I've made it exactly nowhere
whoa who where hey whoa hey whoa
whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
all right well that's a little better
than it was but hi you were trying to
sneak up on me
foreign
oh but I was blocking
oh
well I'm dead like I said about the
combat take some getting used to I think
I went the same direction twice there
and that's why that failed but I'm
trying to understand like how do you
know when something's about to Lunge at
you that's the question I have oh well
I'll figure it out it'll be intuitive
Maybe
oh if you block it so those damage
well I'm learning and trust me lexian is
making this look like I'm much better
than I am right just really combining
and cutting around everything so it's
seamless right in the same combat of the
same enemy so there's just flies from
one to the other so it looks like I
succeeded without a single hit happening
thank you for completing the editor's
oath to make me look as good as possible
at all times
you're the best and because of you
so am I
let's try this again
okay
it's two of you guys how about
[Applause]
it does sound kind of give me some time
oh where'd you come from whoa what the
hell
okay all right that's unfair
[Music]
who are they to throw five at me who are
they to throw five I mean who are they
to throw 12 at me however uh 11 10 9 8 7
6. however many you need Alexian to make
it all seamless and work together my God
they threw an army at me that I totally
beat 100 without ever Dying God damn I'm
just that good that quick it's my gamer
instinct
God damn I'm amazing oh Elias oh you
won't mind probably he's my best friend
he would never mind I love him
well he loves me anyway
maybe I should listen to it I guess
caught me ready
am I going the right way I don't think I
don't think I'm going the right way am I
going the right way I'm not going the
right way
no I'm not going the right way oh this
is back to my cell no I'm dumb I'm dumb
I'm dumb yeah good thing Lucy made it
look like I was going the right way the
first time wow wow here I am at the
right place definitely 100
yep
oh is this not the right oh
oh man all that to go that way
I'm sending in Squad nine uh
we've lost Containment all right then
activate all tactical units you are
weapons free repeat you are weapons free
I would have thought they would have
been weapons free before
no that's in order you kill anything
that moves
hmm well that's probably not good
anyway I hope he doesn't hear this
come on
you
oh how the [__] did you get in here you
think I got time for this [__] okay
okay let me see if I got this straight
uh you crash here
here and then this whole place goes to
[__] oh five two one look at me when I'm
talking to you what'd you do huh you can
do
different are you smashing
wide the warden right
I never told you
it's all yours
well that was fun to watch
so it was fairies
she was there
these things kill them we don't know
about that
yeah unless you see a body you can't
ever assume that anyone's ever done it
but anyway I think I'm going to end this
here I'm out of time roughly I have
thoughts though before I go I have
thoughts I hope I didn't come across as
overly critical in this first episode of
this game it is funny because it is my
first time back in a triple A game and
obviously I play mostly indie games and
so to see a game of this polish in the
graphics so the cutscenes
I assume they'll Iron Out The Kinks and
the stutters and whatnot in patches I'm
not worried about that my Beast of a
computer can do it for the most part
anyway but it's also just like something
about games today they are so incredibly
cinematic and I like cutscenes don't get
me wrong I like a good story I love a
good story but in all honesty in this
first episode I haven't done very much
besides walking and there were some cool
moments that I walked through and walked
up to the doors God you remember the
doors but it's just like it's a trend
where everything is trying to be so
cinematic it's almost like the game is
an afterthought you know like the door
story all right the player has to do
something make a mash e on that put a
fail State into his like you had to
program that in you had that was a
feature you you made that in there and
you you put it in there make this crawl
section really really cool with the
animation so Dynamic and all this stuff
and I'm like all right cool isn't it
funny how the one thing I know is all
those are so nice and whatever but the
thing I noticed is that they use
animation now stands out as odd I use a
button and I'm like your hand isn't even
touching it you have all these really
Dynamic really cool things whereas if
all those were just like I crouched
through and do the crouching animation
which it exists and I go through a hole
without any kind of cinematic
nothingness to it but I noticed that the
door being wonky because everything else
is so polished it's like everything puts
itself up to a certain standard that
anything that doesn't meet it by
comparison just looks worse so it
doesn't matter how good it all looks and
how detailed it is when some small
things out of place it just stands out
all the more whereas like I'm not trying
to be critical again I'm not meaning to
be critical look at this [__] it looks
beautiful it looks incredible look at
all this nut stuff that's going on the
combat's cool I haven't fought that many
enemies but the combat's cool and I'm
learning I just haven't been spooked
that much but I'm looking forward to
more let me know what you thought down
in the comments below I again don't want
to be too critical just my thoughts and
just me being honest about the
experience I'm having fun I would
definitely want to play more I kind of
want to play more when they batch it but
it's still fun I don't want to know your
thoughts on it was this scary to you
I've been playing horror games for 10
years so honestly my scare threshold is
kind of different than everyone else's
but I'm kind of curious
has this spook to you lexian hit him
with a jump scare to end it just because
uh to compare for a scare jump scare is
on the way
you just won't know when
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always
I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]